let me say a quick thank you to Cameron
Llewellyn who is today's new member of
the day Cameron really appreciate your
support appreciate the support of lots
of the people who have signed up for
free and at discounted rates thanks to
all-star member contributor Joshua still
a few memberships remaining if people
want to get in touch
Lance Lawson is today's all-star
sustaining member of the day he's been
with us nearly five years Cameron and
Lance thank you so much sign up for
membership at WWJ pakman.com more than
500 new members already in this very
very early 2019 off - just an amazing
start thank you I mean it's really been
flattering the amount of support growth
that we've seen so far this year and no
better time for it then when we are
launching the show on W CPT in Chicago
hello to everyone listening in Chicago
today's our first day on the air with
you guys and also upcoming DC TV
television in Washington DC the nation's
capital all really really great stuff
let's get into this week's hey tree at
male hey tree at male is when a
professional voice-over artist
interprets hate mail that I get quick
reminder of what it sounds like just to
get everybody on the same page because
we don't care about liberal Kooks so
much that we spend our time writing to
them Patriot Man written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so with most hatred
males there's sort of a balance it's a
kind of seesaw between on the one hand
absolutely incredible hate and ignorance
and on the other hand atrocious spelling
and grammar and you you don't usually
get one hatred mail where both are
really really bad this is an exception
today's Patriot mail is extraordinarily
hateful and disturbing and also just
riddled with bizarre spelling and
grammar mistakes
park Manas avril potting before you have
facts I lost respect for you you are all
about renting's because rantings means
money more BS from Pakman you are a
cuckold in twit you've totally lost my
support on all platforms hi I love that
you've lost my support on all platforms
they're going further than merely saying
they are unsubscribing or they will
never listen to the podcast again every
single platform Instagram this hatred is
gone
Twitter we're never gonna hear from this
hatred again Facebook page has been
unliked and by the way what on earth
does it mean
Parkman is of repotting it seems like
Pakman is report maybe I don't even
really know what this person means but
atrocious spelling atrocious grammar and
of course the hate that we've come to
know and expect in all hatred males but
you are not impotent against the hatreds
there's a coupon code hey tree at 40 H
80 are IOT for zero which will allow you
to save 40% off of any membership at WWE
Ackman calm when you use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 you save 40% and
thousands of hey tree 'it's cry because
their efforts to destroy the David
Pakman show are not functioning and that
is a good thing for everybody on the
side of logic and reason